Free as in beer refers to money.
If someone buys you a beer,
it costs you nothing.
Many versions of Linux are,
in fact, free for you to use.
But just because you get to use it for
free, doesn't mean you get to see
the underlying source code or
modify it for your own purposes.
Free as in speech refers to your
rights or liberties with the software.
You're free to run the software how
you like, see how the software works,
redistribute the software, and
improve upon or modify the software.
This latter definition, free as in
speech, is how Linux became so popular.
There are literally hundreds of versions
or distributions of Linux available.
And it's because of this
latter definition of freedom,
that this became possible.
So with all these different
versions of Linux available,
how do you pick the right one?